okay the moment many people have been
waiting for I've been teasing it on
social media this week's hatred mail is
really good but if you've never heard
hatred mail before I'll remind you what
it is it's like a mandatory transvaginal
ultrasound for your mind
Patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom all right very serious
allegations being made about me in this
week's hatred mail this is not the type
of thing that I would joke about very
very serious allegations I'll play them
for you first and then we'll discuss
David Pakman is a violent homosexual not
that bad to be a queer but to do violent
things to young boy's is inexcusable
David is as gay as hell not that I don't
think he has this right to be queer but
he looks like a very effeminate man or
woman your site is apparently on a list
of extremist propaganda compiled by a
private advisory panel to the Federal
Government of Canada thanks and please
find a new avenue for the lies spewed by
the supposed gay activist David pecan uh
David pecan that is apparently my new
last name pecan I like that they add
it's not that it's bad to be gay it's
bad that David is molesting little kids
which of course is a baseless allegation
that which I shouldn't even have to
defend myself against um this is a very
very like a it's just very dark in some
way I'm on some propaganda list in
Canada according to some private how
does someone even come up with this well
it has that offensive false association
between homosexuality and pedophilia of
course I mean that's a given I did we
have a pat pat pat sakteng chuck is like
hey you know it's weird David sometimes
people who are homophobic also think
that gay people are child sex predators
or something like that welcome to
hadrian males have rude awakening there
we're not really on any kind of list in
Canada are we that's the thing also I
mean he seems to know a lot about this
private advisory panel for the federal
of Canada but then he can't really give
any specifics and he said apparently so
I guess he doesn't even know for sure
it's very strange and the only thing I
can say with certitude about this hatred
mail is that if you disagree with this
hatred you can use the coupon code
hatred for tea to turn hatred mail into
something you benefit from and we
benefit from by becoming a member at
david pakman.com slash membership using
the coupon code patriot 40